- [Kelly Clarkson] So everyone
also knows you as Shorty,
from Indiana Jones as well,
which you've been in such
epic films, like right off
the bat, at such a young age.
So, do you remember working
with Harrison Ford? Or?
- [Ke Huy Quan] Yeah! Oh
my God, it was incredible!
- [Kelly Clarkson] You've
worked with some awesome people,
right off the bat!
- [Ke Huy Quan] Well, yeah,
first time ever, right?
Yeah, he was incredible,
he was like one of the most
generous, down to earth
human beings I've ever met.
And I remember we shot a
lot of the exterior stuff
in Sri Lanka and we all
stayed in this hotel.
And every day after we wrapped,
we would go and hang out
at the swimming pool.
And when Harrison Ford found
out that I didn't know how
to swim, he says, Keith,
come on, let me teach you.
So to this day, I learned how
to swim, it's because of him.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Harrison
Ford taught you how to swim?
What is your life?
All I had a swim instructor
at the Y or something like,
you know, and I was like,
wait, what? That's crazy.
I love that that because it's
not always that way for kids,
like starting out.
Like, I love that that was
such a positive experience,
right off the bat, that's so cool.
- [Ke Huy Quan] I got
really lucky, I mean,
who would've thought, right?
I mean, get to work with,
I mean, Steven Spielberg, George Lucas
and Harrison Ford?
- [Kelly Clarkson] (laughs)
Right off the bat, yeah!